problems persist with the united states
postal service in an effort to balance
the postal service budget the postmaster
general slowing down some deliveries and
raising prices this all coming ahead of
the holiday season
[Music]
starting today some mail from the u.s
postal service could take longer and
cost more we
oppose those things that diminish
service to the people of the country
mark diamondstein president of the
american postal workers union says
slower standards and higher prices will
drive away business but usps says the
new time frame allows them to shift more
of its delivery service away from air
transportation to cheaper ground
transportation we don't buy those
arguments uh we think there's ways to
fix the service
without moving the gold posts the postal
service claims the move will improve
efficiency of first-class mail delivery
but virginia democratic senator tim
kaine wants the agency to put customers
first
we're dealing with a system where
people aren't getting you know people
who have bills to pay are paying them
and then they're not getting there on
time and it could affect their credit
rating kane says his bill would increase
delivery times and drive down costs he
calls the system broken and wants to see
changes starting at the top i believe
the the current
postmaster general who was appointed by
president trump has played a key role in
breaking it this all comes at a cost
almost 40 percent of first class mail
could take up to five days to arrive
instead of up to three and sending
holiday cheer will be pricier as well
with postage rates increasing up to five
dollars more per package until december
26th